[Music]
did you guys miss today last 24 hours
has been completely insane because I
have not had power and ice taken out
games over here she is we're basically
having a dog park right now we've got
dizzy and rocky and Maddy look at the
puppies you smell like buttermilk
pancakes honey you can't get out the
food's here so I think it's mine Oh
Maddy I'm used to so much I haven't seen
my babies in ten days we're having a
feast look at you
where's Maddy at oh there he is oh he's
like will you be my baby my daddy they
are real sharp
that's Junior this is exactly what I
ordered so Justine except I thought I
got cheese pizza I'm so sorry guys you
can pick up what I mean but I just don't
[Applause]
oh my gosh
rock band Maddie honey please stop
itching yourself do you want to go
outside stop itching babe look at your
jammies you look so handsome in your
jammies we're gonna take maybe for a
walk but first I got to get his jammies
off Jenna's here yeah I'm in Rio Jimmy's
as well I stopped itching your little
bleep getting the jammies off is a
struggle no I've got one you want to
tell people why he has this jammies he
has jammies on because he itches his
body he's like into death to death so if
we as long as we have like all most of
the parts covered these Alexei look stop
it no people do it come on I'd like
another coffee I've only had two today
like I gotta like act like I'm gonna
pick him up just to get him to you if
not poop to yet today yeah it's a little
disconcerting
I'll stop bitching so I think we left
off we're in a rock band party we walked
the dog and now we plan on going to the
Cielo game but then some things happen I
could find Matty a babysitter bully last
minute found that eBay so yeah within an
hour we bought tickets we're now driving
to Burbank to drop Maddie off to a
babysitter and
if JB and maybe inquire about your
indigestion my apartment all the way to
Mexico think about that Burbank to
Mexico Jaime rode his bike 2008 we're on
our way to the ceiling it clearly matias
at its peak I need Gayle texty when the
time is right okay well first quarter is
currently over second quarter is an
obsession but we made it here like we're
here we're now taking an uber stadium
yeah some things that happened that
basically said the same thing that I
would have said in his vlog so you know
whatever and nursing about my blog has
great insight to today I think the first
time you've ever said anything in my one
of my videos what this is the first one
I think so check my for great insight on
today
[Music]
yeah we gotta go go baby go go we made
it we made it we're on it yet wait what
the tickets yes oh geez
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
I can't breathe
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm here they had to come out honey
let's go come on come on out come on out
let's chipper buddy here your fresh bath
all right well Maggie got himself a nice
fresh little bath today he's still
itching himself to death I'm going crazy
because I don't know what to do and I am
feeling completely helpless it's like
what do i do I don't know what to I'm
doing everything possible and like
nothing's working
I know it takes time but I got him a
nice fun little toy you guys know his
favorite toy was lamb chop so I got him
a massive lamb chop makes your heart a
ghost town huh is your heart ghost town
there's no one left in the world that
can do with Maddy's itchin look at you
sweet soul yeah okay but get it this is
something I thought that you might be
into for being such a good boy the
groomers getting brushed oh my God he's
adorable I love him I'll see you guys
later
stay tuned for Buri vlog we were going
to do an original take on pizza and I am
going to be making pizza cupcakes